今実は保存して超です皆さんは滑舌悪い人見たことありますでしょうか
僕も結構人なりに滑舌がおまあ今出ましたけど僕も間を1台に確実が悪いんですよけど
世の中には数え世がもっともっと悪い人たくさんいると思いますあのお笑い芸人のもと
ハムの物見山と山
ローソンをローソンというぐらい
貫通ぜつが悪い方もいると思うけど世の中には不思議がいっぱい
もっともっとかぜつが悪い人がいるかも知れませんってはそんな滑舌の世界を皆さんに
ご紹介したいと思います滑舌
世界第8位
自己紹介をお願いしますえっ
ん浦和サポーター通りは論文
んまーいアイスマーシャルなのでどうぞ
そうございます今日2やっちゃうからよろしくね
私はですまずはしておりましたが今の anza 幹部ですから名前ば夫婦ある
[音楽]
ブーブー言っは
ブーブー誰だそれ
[拍手]
ブービー皆付き合い
ダーツ好きな食べ物は音符オニュヒョン
右打ちという今ね彼の3文字クイッっ方ありが寒いなんて言ったかを当てるクイズ王
すごいですバラすこれはなかなかの難問だそう
夢このをに服のポニョ言葉を理解出来ればた一定のかなぁ
滑舌悪い人の言葉だが願いできる間違えるんでもう最悪
もう理解できたら動物との関係9キーが coo
14にとってあげることが大事だよねうーん
問題ですよ村分散も作りさんマジックないかも4日待ってるよろしくありません
ラブライブ風ぐらい100
う
f 3本柱ですか言ってるらしいねって言って吹いて聴いてみればぞっ
ブーブー
の全然違ういるうーん
こんにゃろ
正解は吉でした kitchen
運慶今回です
西軍ずっとあったんですよねこの言われてみれば何となくそうかのそうアホになって
そう
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーバーそれっね
ブーブー行き一
大きい漆器 haejin
あーなんかねえこんなね選ぶんだけど
4種ぼっち逆前科って言うだろ
[音楽]
しかしばサーズネットウヨいい色紙
ティッシュじゃない使い午馬
ブービー中6乳首
近く行ってみていくんおーん
[音楽]
ブーブー
ぶーぶーっ
俺いや
[音楽]
ge キーうーんうーん
好きちほんんん
ああああああ
あう
横瀬ないか4した
ブーブー言ってるだけですね滑舌世界初位は今のような実力者でございますみなさんと
いったロサて最後
で冠絶追われ方を交えてあとちょっと
日常の風景の映像をつくってみまして
まあそれで皆さんに読み取れるかどうかを最後にチェックしていただきたいと思います
ではどうぞ
[音楽]
ん
主にも前の橋の
[音楽]
はいというわけでみなさまいかがだったでしょうか先生が会話の中で何をおっしゃった
のかわかりますでしょうか
堀もまでの俺から
先生早速答えの方をよろしくお願い致します
小山会はが入ったらん
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ